CALL THE OF PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE MEETING TO ORDER- BUT
FIRST I NEED TO READ. THE
COVERT DISCLAIMER SO I'VE
OFFICIALLY CALLED THE MEETING
TO ORDER- WE'LL WAIT UNTIL WE
CAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM WE HAVE
THREE MEMBERS HE FELT I'M SORRY.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME. HELLO
YEAH ONCE AGAIN I'M CALLING
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE MEETING
TO ORDER- ONE TWENTY THREE
LET'S US TRY TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM WE HAVE FIVE. SO LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. JONES
SAWYER HERE LACKEY CARE
BARRICADE HAND COURT SANTIAGO
C. R. TO HEAR THEIR TENTH YEAR
WICKS LEE. RIGHT SO LET ME
BEGIN WITH OUR OUR HOUSEKEEPING
ITEMS FOR TODAY'S HEARING WE
HAVE- WE HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALIX NOTICES ALEX LEAVING HERE
WELL. OKAY FOR TODAY'S HEARING
WE HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALEX
LEE FILLING THE VACANCY WHO ARE
COMMITTEE AGAIN THIS WEEK. DUE
TO THE ONGOING COVERT NINETEEN
SAFETY CONSIDERATIONS INCLUDING
GUIDANCE ON PHYSICAL DISTANCING
SEATING FOR THIS HEARING WILL
BE VERY LIMITED FOR PRESS AND
FOR THE PUBLIC ALL ENCOURAGED
TO WATCH THE HEARING FROM HIS
LIVE STREAM ON THE ASSEMBLY
WEBSITE. THE CAPITAL WILL BE
OPEN FOR ATTENDANCE OF THIS
HEARING BUT THE PUBLIC IS
STRONGLY ENCOURAGED TO
PARTICIPATE VIA THE WEB PORTAL
OR PHONE ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC ATTENDING THE HEARING IN
THE CAPITOL WILL NEED TO WEAR A
MASK AT ALL TIMES WHILE IN THE
BUILDING. WE ENCOURAGE THE
PUBLIC TO MONITOR THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE FOR UPDATES
WE WILL ALSO BE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS.
877-692-8957 AGAIN THAT'S EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR TWO ZERO TWO. AGAIN THAT'S
ONE. THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR TWO
ZERO TWO. YOU CAN ALSO FIND THE
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS
WELL AS ON YOUR TV SCREEN. ALSO
PLEASE ALSO BE ADVISED THAT IF
YOU ARE A MAIN WITNESS-
PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR OR
AGAINST THE BILL YOU WILL
REMAIN ON A LIFELINE IT WILL
NEED TO MEET YOURSELF UNTIL
YOU'RE CALLED ON TO SPEAK. IF
YOU'RE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH
THE MODERATE PHONE SERVICE YOU
CAN CALL THE COMMITTEE AT NINE
ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE THREE
SEVEN FOUR FOUR AGAIN THAT'S
NINE ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE
THREE SEVEN FOUR FOUR AND MY
STAFF WILL BE THERE TO TRY TO
HELP. I ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT
WE ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY TO THE POSITION
LETTER PORTAL. ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. COLTON
COMMITTEE TO ORDER. WE ONLY
HAVE ONE ITEM ON THE AGENDA OF
THE- AB ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE
CRISTINA GARCIA- SPOUSAL RAPE.
AND I BELIEVE THE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN IS HERE. YOU MAY BEGIN AT
ANY TIME. ONLY NINE STATES THAT
DISTINGUISHED ALSO RIGHT FROM
DOWN SOUTH OF RAPE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WE ARE ONE OF
THEM- WE FELL ON THE I'LL BE
BRIEF AND I'LL LET MY
WITNESSES- AT THE PLACES THAT
HAS LIKE MESSED MY LIFE UP.
OPERATOR YOU MAY OPEN UP THE
LINE FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
OF A. B. ELEVEN SEVEN ONE
GARCIA RATE OF SPOUSE. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SERVE SHOW
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME FOR THAT
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY THE ZERO AND EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATOR WILL I GIVE YOU MY
NUMBER OFF LINE IN THE PLACE
YOU BACK INTO THE QUEUE SO
AGAIN TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT.
BECAUSE HE WON FALL BUDGET DEAL.
DO YOU HAVE SPECIFIC PEOPLE ARE
NICE TO YOU A HARDWARE THEIR
NAMES BECAUSE I DON'T REALLY.
WE WERE GOING PRETTY FAST SO-
YOU CAN HANDLE. DEEPER ALSO.
YOU MAY BEGIN I PRESIDENT.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY YOU MAY
BEGIN. OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH I
WANT TO START BY THANKING EACH
AND EVERYONE OF THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE MEMBERS- INTO
THE CHAIR ASSEMBLY MEMBER SO I
JONES REGARDING ACTIVE HEARING
TO ASSEMBLYMEMBERS CORRECT
CRISTINA GARCIA AND EVAN LOW
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
JOIN YOU THIS EVENING AND FOR
TAKING UP IT'S VERY CRITICAL.
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE MY
NAME IS KANIKA SIEGEL AND I'M
THE FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION FOR WOMEN
SINCE OUR FOUNDING IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE. INNING VIOLENCE
AGAINST WOMEN HAS BEEN ONE OF
OUR CORE ISSUES SPECIFICALLY
CALIFORNIA NOW HAS BEEN AT THE
FOREFRONT STYLE THE RATE OF
THIS BROKERAGE ISSUE SINCE.
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN AND THIS
IS LONG OVERDUE. WE RIDE TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE ONE
SEVENTY ONE AND CALL FOR AN END
TO THE FELLOW. CALIFORNIA WE
ARE THE STORIES FROM SURVIVORS
IN OUR MEMBERSHIP AND ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. AND I'M
HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THEM.
WE RIDE FOR THE SAFETY AND
PROTECTION OF THE MARRIED
WOMAN'S CHANCES WE WOULD FOR
THE SUPPORT OF THE SINGLE ONE.
SINGLE WOMAN AS THIS CRIME AND
ITS IMPACT ON THE SAME. THE
BIGGEST PROBLEM HERE IS THE
ANTIQUATED THINKING SURROUNDING
SEXUAL ASSAULT- AND ENDED
INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE OUR
COLLECTIVE IGNORANCE ON HOW WE
DEFINE AND YOU VICTIMS. AND THE
DISREGARD FOR THE CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE OF CONSENT ALSO
GOING TO ADD WE HAVE AN
INABILITY TO CALL A SPADE A
SPADE. MY MESSAGE TODAY IS VERY
VERY SIMPLE. RAPE IS RAPE IF
YOU'RE A COLLEGE STUDENT RAPE
IS RAPE IF YOU'RE A WOMAN OF
COLOR. WAIT THAT'S GREAT IF
YOU'RE TRANS WOMAN'S RAPE IS
RAPE IF YOU'RE A SEX WORKER AND
RAPE IS RAPE WHETHER YOU'RE
MARRIED OR NOT. WE CALIFORNIANS.
FARMS OF THE WHOLE WOMAN ACROSS
THE INTERSECTIONAL IDENTIFIERS
AND WE ASK THAT YOU STAND WITH
SURVIVORS. AS WE CALL FOR AN
END TO THE SITUATIONAL SUPPORT
THE VICTIMS. AB ONE ONE SEVENTY
ONE DOES JUST THAT. AND THEY
WOULD PROVIDE PARITY IN
CALIFORNIA LAW AND REQUIRED THE
SAME STANDARDS FOR THE REST OF
THE FILES. THAT ARE CURRENTLY
IN THE PENAL CODE FOR THE RAPE
OF AN OUT OF A NON SPOUSE. YOU
ARE CONVICTED UNDER THE RAPE IN
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY MAKE BANKS
LESS SEVERE SENTENCING. AND
THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE FULL STOP.
ONE MARITAL RAPE IS NOT TREATED
AS SERIOUSLY AS NON MERIT A
WHITE. IT INVALIDATES THE VERY
DRAMATIC IMPACT ON THE
SURVIVORS WHO SHOULD BE. AND
REMAIN OUR FOCUS. WHEN IT
SHOULD NEVER BE SHIELDED WITH
SPECIAL TREATMENT WITHIN THIS
LOOPHOLE AND THAT INCLUDES- NOT
BEING REQUIRED TO REGISTER AS A
SEX OFFENDER AFTER BEING
CONVICTED OF SUCH CRIMES. IN
CLOTHING ACCORDING TO THE
NATIONAL COALITION AGAINST
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE BETWEEN
10214% OF MARRIED WOMEN HAVE
BEEN OR MAY EXPERIENCE RATE BY
THEIR SPOUSE. AND DURING THIS
GLOBAL PANDEMIC FOR THE
MESSAGING IS WE ARE SAFER AT
HOME I'M HERE TO REMIND US ALL
THAT NO NOT ALL OF US ARE IN
FACT A THRESHOLDS AND RATES OF
DOMESTIC AND SEXUAL VIOLENCE.
ARE INCREASING. WEIGHT THE
DIRECT REGARDLESS. AND AB ONE
ONE SEVENTY ONE ELIMINATES THE
DISTINCTION SO WE CAN ENSURE
JUSTICE FOR SURVIVORS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU. DO YOU
HAVE ANY OTHER YES WE HAVE- DA
BERBER. THANK YOU D. A. BIRD
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY TO
TESTIFY. GREAT THANK YOU THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN JONES SAWYER AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR YOUR TIME
AND ATTENTION TO THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE AND THE SPECIAL THANK YOU
TO A FAMILY MEMBER GARCIA. AND
SENATOR KERR KATIE FOR SERVING
AS CHAMPIONS FOR SURVIVORS OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT AND AUTHOR OF
THREE THIS CHANGE THE LAW.
OTHER COMMUNITIES CALL FOR
RAISING VICTIM SURVIVOR VOICES
AND HOLDING ACCOUNTABLE THOSE
WHO ENGAGE IN SEXUAL VIOLENCE.
CALIFORNIA LAW CONTINUE TO
PERPETRATE CENTURY OLD INHUMANE
INEQUITABLE PRACTICES THAT
REINFORCE THE IDEA THAT IT FELT
IT SEXUAL PROPERTY. ACTUAL
PROPERTY AND PROVIDE EVERY
VOCAL CONSENT THIS IS WRONG AND
WE MUST CORRECT IT AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY ONE PROVIDE PARITY IN
CALIFORNIA LAW THAT WOULD
REQUIRE THE STATE STANDARDS FOR
SPOUSAL RAPE THAT ARE CURRENTLY
IN THE PENAL CODE. RAKE IS
UNIVERSALLY ACKNOWLEDGED AT THE
CRIME OF VIOLENCE. IT BIRKHEAD
SICKLY IN PSYCHOLOGICALLY
HARMFUL TO THE VICTIM. HERE IN
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE WHO ARE
CONVICTED UNDER PSALTERY BOX
MAKE MAKE A LEFT AND WE'RE
SENSING. PROTECTED UNDER
REGISTRY REQUIREMENTS. WHICH IS
NOT A PARENT WITH OTHER. STATE
CHARGES. ONE MARITAL RAPE IS
NOT TREATED AS SERIOUSLY AS
OTHER FUNDING RATE IT
INVALIDATES. THE VICTIMS
TRAUMATIC EXPERIENCE WITH A
CONTINUES TO PROMOTE A RAPE
CULTURE. IT INVALIDATE THE
VICTIM'S TRAFFIC EXPERIENCE.
THANK YOU WE NEED TO PROMOTE
RAPE CULTURE CRIMES INVOLVING
SEXUAL ASSAULT AND VIOLENCE
HAVE A UNIQUE IMPACT ON
SURVIVORS OFFERING LAYERED WITH
EXTENSIVE TRAUMA RESPONSE TO IS
A LONG LASTING IMPACT OF TRAUMA
OCCURRED REGARDLESS OF THE
RELATIONSHIP THAT AT THE MINUTE
TALENT WITH THE SURVIVOR. OF
SEXUAL VIOLENCE. MOREOVER A
PERSON WHO COMMITS RAPE SHOULD
NOT BE SHIELDED FROM
ACCOUNTABILITY. SIMPLY BECAUSE
THEY ARE MARRIED TO THE VICTIM.
A CERTIFICATE OF MERIT SHOULD
NOT PROVIDE MORE LENIENT LEGAL
OUTCOME. REGARDLESS OF THE RATE
OF THE RELATIONSHIP BREAKAGE
RATE. AB ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE
ELIMINATE THIS DISTINCTION SO
WE CAN ENSURE JUSTICE FOR
VICTIMS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT. AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE RETAIL
CONSTRUCTION TO SIXTY EACH YEAR
IN THE LEAGUE. THE ANTIQUATED
AND DISCRIMINATORY LANGUAGE OF
NOT THE SOUTH OF THE
PERPETRATOR WENT PEAK P.
SECTION TWO SIXTY ONE AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY ONE IS A PRACTICAL AND
NECESSARY CHANGE IN THE LAW
ADDRESSING AN ARCHAIC PROVISION
THE CALIFORNIA PENAL CODE THAT
DOES NOT PROTECT. ALL SURVIVORS
OF SEXUAL ASSAULT. THERE'S
PRESIDENT FROM SEVERAL OTHER
STATES FOR THE PROPOSED CHANGE
TOMORROW. AND ALTHOUGH STATE
THAT WATER RATES IN SOME FORM
CALIFORNIA REMAINS ONE OF A
SMALL HANDFUL OF STATES THAT
CONTINUE TO DISTINGUISH.
BETWEEN OPERATE OR NOT OPERATE
AND TREATED AS A FAR LESS
SERIOUS CRIME. CALIFORNIA
SHOULD JOIN THE MAJORITY ON
THIS CRITICAL ISSUE FOR THIS
REASON I AND MANY OTHERS THE
COURT AB ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE I
HEARD YOUR AYE VOTES TO REPAIR.
AN INEXCUSABLE WRONG IN OUR
CRIMINAL. LEGAL SYSTEM THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
KNOW OPENED UP TO INDIVIDUALS
IN ROME DON'T SEE NONE OF. HI
HI I WAS. WE HAVE A WE HAVE TO
LISTEN WE HAVE TO GET PUBLIC
COMMENT FIRST. YES- UNTIL WHO
IT ARE THERE ANY ONCE IN THE
TELE COMMUNICATION ROOM SEEN
NONE- EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR
COULD YOU PLEASE OPEN UP-
DEADLINE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
FOUR AB ELEVEN SEVEN ONE.
SUPPORT SUPPORT THANK YOU
SUPPORT SUPPORT. THANK YOU TO
SHOW YOUR SUPPORT ONLY AT THIS
TIME FOR- AB ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AND EIGHTEEN CAPITAL GIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER OFFLINE AN
INCREASE YOU BACK IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT. AND
WILL BEGIN TODAY MISTER CHAIR
WITH- LINE SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD SIXTY TWO. NAME AN
ORGANIZATION PLEASE THANK YOU.
WELL WELL NEXT WILL THE LINE
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES I CAN
NAME AN ORGANIZATION PLEASE
THANK YOU. R. MY NAME IS ANNE
MANNARINO AND I AM A VOTER IN
CALIFORNIA AND I HAVE
EXPERIENCE HAVING WORKED-
MANAGING A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SEXUAL ASSAULT HOTLINE. THANK
YOU AND YOUR SUPPORT. YES I AM
IN SUPPORT AND I WANT TO OFFER
A COUPLE MOMENTS THANK YOU. IS
NOT POSSIBLE NAME AN
ORGANIZATION B. GO TO NEXT LINE.
THANK YOU NEXT OVER THE LINE
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE SIXTY ONE YOU ARE OPEN. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. TRY ONE THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS BRADLEY LOGAN WENT
ACTION TOGETHER BAY AREA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
JUST JUST SO EVERYONE KNOWS WE
USUALLY HAVE TWO SPEAKERS THAT
ARE GIVEN FIVE MINUTES TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT AND JUST LIKE WE'RE
GOING TO DO THE SAME PER PERSON
OPPOSITION AND THEN FOR ME TO
USE OTHERS THAT WANT TO ADD ON.
IS YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION
SO I APOLOGIZE FOR CUTTING OFF
THE ONE BEFORE BUT THIS IS THIS
IS THE PRINCIPLES AND PRACTICE
A POLICY OF THE COMMITTEE SO
AT&T OPERATOR YOU CAN BEGIN
WITH THE NEXT ONE NAME AN
ORGANIZATION. EIGHT ARE WE GOOD
AGENT OPERATORS IS THERE
SOMEONE ON THE LINE MOMENT YEP
YES WE ARE READY TO GIVE US ONE
MOMENT THANK YOU. JUSTIN. NINE
SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS COURTNEY BROWN
BELOW I'M FROM TAYLOR
CALIFORNIA AND- GEN AND I AM
FOR A BI ELEVEN FIFTY ONE.
THANK YOU. THANKS. FIFTY EIGHT.
LINE FIFTY FIVE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS SEAN HICKEY ROCKS SAN
JOSE I AM IN SUPPORT OF AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE. THANK YOU.
THANK. SIXTY SEVEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS JENNIFER GONZALEZ AND
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
OFFICE OF THE SENATE GOVERNOR
OF AND YOU CAN UNLOCK IT AS A
PRACTICAL SPONSORED AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY ONE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK. SEVENTY ONE. HI
JENNY HUTCHINSON WITH ENOUGH
WITHOUT FURTHER PROJECT I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NINE SIXTY NINE. THIS IS
FLORIDA RAN FROM SAN JOSE
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT EIGHTY ELEVEN SEVENTY
ONE. THANK YOU. NO FOR THE
QUESTIONS TO BY PHONE. HUH WHAT
DID YOU SAY OPERATE. SHOWING NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS FOR THE
QUESTIONS OKAY. I'M AT- NOW WE
GO TO WE DID JUST GET ANOTHER
ONE YOU IT UP OKAY. ABOUT LINE
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD WE HAD.
YOU MAY BEGIN NAME IN ORDER. TO
THEY TOOK THEMSELVES OUT OF
QUEUE SORRY OKAY SO NOW WILL GO
TO- WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
AB ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE I BELIEVE
WE HAVE A MARGOT GEORGE FROM
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION. I
APOLOGIZE I DON'T THINK YOU CAN
HEARME THAT THIS IS TWENTY
PURPOSE SOUTH ARE THERE'S A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE ONLINE IN
SUPPORT AND THEY'VE BEEN UNABLE
TO ACCESS THE SYSTEM SAID MAYBE
WHAT KIND OF CIRCLE BACK TO
THAT- DEFINITELY. YES THE VERY
MUCH I APPRECIATE THAT. HELP.
WE HAVE SEVENTY PEOPLE ONLINE
IN THE CLEAR CRITICAL THINKING
OF A GREAT NUMBER OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE WAITING- TO GET IT CAN
BE SUSPENDED ON THE PORTAL.
HELLO BUT- IT. ONE MOMENT. HOW
MANY PEOPLE DO YOU SHOULD. THE
AB ONE MOMENT WHAT WE DID WITH
THAT SIDE OF THE COURT REVERSED
OUT OF REACH. WIND UP IN THE
QUEUE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THAT IT I WAITING AND THEY KEEP
TAPPING ONE ZERO AND THEY ARE
BEING ACCESSED I JUST WANNA
GIVE YOU HAD THAT THE STATE
WILL BE COULD CIRCLE BACK ON
THAT- AND GIVE THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HEARD. SHE
WAS ONE DOLLAR. THANK SO WHAT
IS FAMILIES ARE WE GOING TO
OPPOSITION AND THEN COME BACK
TO THEM. BUT I'D LIKE TO GO TO
OPPOSITION AND COME BACK. SO
MARGO GEORGE WOULD LIKE TO HEAR
FROM HER. ANYWAY YEAH OKAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS I'M MARCO GEORGE
FOR THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION I
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION
WITH THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE AND
HOPE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE THE
DIALOGUE WE NEED MORE TIME ON
THIS BILL FOR ALL OF US TO
UNDERSTAND THE BACKGROUND AND
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES. AT
THIS TIME WE MUST REMAIN IN
OPPOSITION TO AB. ELEVEN
SEVENTY ONE EIGHTEEN ELEVEN
SEVENTY ONE TAKES DISCRETION
FROM JUDGES DISMISSES THE
DESIRES AND NEEDS OF VICTIMS
AND STRIPPED DEVELOPMENTALLY
AND PHYSICALLY DISABLED
CALIFORNIANS FROM THE CAPACITY
TO CONSENT TO SEXUAL ACTIVITY
WITH THEIR SPOUSES. ON A
PERSONAL NOTE AS A RAPE
SURVIVOR AND A PUBLIC DEFENDER.
WE ALL WANT TO END RIGHT THAT
TOOK COMPANY LOS WILL NOT
CHANGE RAPE CULTURE IN THIS
COUNTRY. I WANT TO TALK BRIEFLY
ABOUT THE HISTORY OF GREAT LOSS
AND THE FUTILITY OF HARSH
PUNISHMENT FOR RAPE AND THE
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON
PEOPLE OF COLOR. IN NINETEEN
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTEEN OF FORTY
EIGHT STATES THE DISTRICT OF
COLUMBIA AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT COSTA BRYCE THE
DEATH PENALTY FOR RAPE OF AN
ADULT WOMAN. I NINETEEN SEVENTY
ONE ON THE EVE OF THE U. S.
SUPREME COURT'S BERMAN DECISION
FINDING THAT THE DEATH PENALTY
WAS UNCONSTITUTIONAL. THE
NUMBER OF JURISDICTIONS
SUPPORTING THE DEATH PENALTY
FOR RAPE OF AN ADULT WOMAN HAD
DECLINED TO SIXTEEN STATES AND
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. I GREW
UP IN JIM CROW GEORGIA WHERE
CONVICTION FOR RAPE COULD BRING
THE DEATH PENALTY. THAT DID NOT
THEN WAIT IT ONLY MEANT THAT
MOST OF THE PEOPLE WHO WERE
CHARGED CONVICTED AND SENTENCED
TO DEATH FOR BLACK MEN ACCUSED
OF RAPING WHITE WOMEN. IN FACT
IN GEORGIA THE GREAT HAD
INITIALLY BEEN DEFINED AS ONLY
THE RATE OF EIGHT WHITE FEMALE
BY A BLACK MAN. IN NINETEEN
TWENTY FOUR HENSON HOWARD A
BLACK MAN WAS THE FIRST PERSON.
ALECTRA Q. DID BY THE STATE OF
GEORGIA WEDNESDAY. ENTRY FOR
RIGHT AND BARBARI WHEN THEY
FIRST USED ELECTRIC CHAIR.
TODAY TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
CALIFORNIA WE'RE TRYING TO
LEARN TO THE RAVAGES OF MASS
INCARCERATION WE'RE TRYING TO
RECLAIM OUR BUDGET FROM CDC ARE
AND STANDARD INSTEAD FOR
COMMUNITY PROGRAMS WHICH MAKE
PEOPLE SAFER AND HE'LL PEOPLE
WHO SUFFER FROM MENTAL OR
SUBSTANCE ABUSE PROBLEMS SO
THAT THEY WILL NOT HARM OTHERS
OR THEMSELVES. AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY ONE IS A THROWBACK TO
AN EARLIER FAILED PUBLIC POLICY
WHERE WE START TO SOLVE OUR
SOCIAL PROBLEMS BY SENDING ALL
OFFENDERS TO STATE PRISON. AND
ADDING ALL SEX OFFENDERS TO SEX
OFFENDER REGISTRIES. AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY ONE WILL TAKE
DISCRETION AWAY FROM OUR JUDGES
AND REQUIRE THEM TO SENATE
ALMOST THE WHOLE TOWN RATE THIS
TO STATE PRISON AND LIFETIME
SEX OFFENDER REGISTRATION.
REGARDLESS OF THE VICTIM'S
WISHES OUR ECONOMIC NEEDS. AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE MORE
CRIMINALIZED THE SEXUAL LIVES
OF THE SPOUSES OF
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED AND
PHYSICALLY DISABLED INDIVIDUALS
SINCE UNDER THE RAPE LAWS THE
INDIVIDUAL MODE THAT THE
DISABILITY WILL BE DEALING TO
HAVE NO CAPACITY TO CONSENT TO
SEX. I BELIEVE THAT TO END RAPE
CULTURE WE MUST EDUCATE OUR
CHILDREN ABOUT WOMEN'S HISTORY
AND SPEAK OUT. NOT SEND MORE
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESENT AND
MAKE THEM UNEMPLOYABLE WHEN
THEY ARE RELEASED BECAUSE
THEY'RE ON AN INTERNET SEX
REGISTRY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR NO VOTE ON AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU. ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ARE ANY WITNESSES
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. RT
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION A
TELEPROMPTER AND ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ON THE
TELEPHONE LINE EIGHTEEN T.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION NAME
AND ORGANIZATION ONLY. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND AGAIN-
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TO SHOW
OPPOSITION. AND WE WILL BEGIN
WITH THE ONLINE SEVENTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SEVENTY SEVENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE ON MUTE.
WHY SEVENTY CAN YOU HARRIS. I'M
SORRY PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY GO
AHEAD WITH MY NAME MY NAME IS
JENNY AGAIN AND I REPRESENTED
YOU ORGANIZATIONS WOMEN'S MARCH
JOSE AND THE DEMOCRATIC
ACTIVISTS FOR WOMEN NOW I'M
SANTA CLARA COUNTY AND I IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE SEVENTY ONE
AND I URGE YOU TO HAPPEN NOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- LEVERAGES
OPEN UP THE LINE TO SUPPORT AN
OPPOSITION THEY JUST STATE WHAT
IT IS AND WE JUST DO IT ALL AT
ONE TIME. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- TO SHOW THEIR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE SEVENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
KARLEY HAS BROKE I LIVE IN
CAMPBELL CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO PASS THE
BALL. THANK YOU. ONE SEVENTY
SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN. HELLO THIS
IS KRISTEN RIVERS- CALLING FROM
SAN JOSE. AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
SURVIVORS BOTH THOSE WHO ARE
MARRIED TO THEIR PERPETRATORS
AND THOSE WHO ARE NOT. PLEASE
VOTE FOR THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. AND LIKE SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
MICHELLE DAUBER I AM A
PROFESSOR OF LAW AT STANFORD
LAW SCHOOL AND THEN THE CHAIR
OF THE ENOUGH IS ENOUGH VOTER
PROJECT AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL WHICH IS A MUCH
NEEDED CORRECTIVE TO THE
INJUSTICE OF THE SPOUSAL RAPE
EXCEPTION. THANK YOU. MOVING
ALONG WITH A LINE SEVENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SEVENTY EIGHT
YOUR OPEN YOUR- ALL THE- THAT
IS YOU. SEVENTY EIGHT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO COMMENT. LOPING ALONG
WE WILL ALIGN SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MAIN TO
SAY- JONES SAWYER AND THAT MANY
MEMBERS RETIRE ATTENTION ON
THIS ISSUE AND ALSO LIKE TO
THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA
HARPER LEADERSHIP AND- I'M THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY OF THE CITY
AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO I
MERGING YOUR SUPPORT. BILL I
THINK IT'S A CRITICAL MOMENTS
TOO THANK YOU FORWARD AS A
STATE TO. SOME OF THE
HISTORICAL RECORD IS LIKE THAT-
UNDERMINE WOMEN'S RIGHTS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT. NAME AN
ORGANIZATION. WHY SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DANIEL
GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. THANK
YOU. LINE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RIGHT SIXTY FOUR PLEASE
ON MUTE YOU ARE OPEN. HELLO YES
NAME AN ORGANIZATION. YOUR PROP
YOUR SALIVA CALIFORNIA REPORT
THANK YOU. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LOW YES YOUR OPEN. MEMORIZATION
CHAIRMAN THE SHERMAN MEMBERS
TEMPLES OUT ON BEHALF OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THE FINAL REMINDER
TO OUR SHOW OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
MISTER CARE NOBODY ELSE'S
QUEUING UP. OKAY THANK YOU SO
WE'LL BRING IT IN. TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REBEKAH POWER CAN THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I JUST
WANTTO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
HER DILIGENCE AND HARD WORK ON
THIS MATTER I THINK THAT THE
FIRST WITNESS SAID IT BEST THAT
RAPE IS RAPE FULL STOP I DON'T
THINK THERE SHOULD BE ANY
DISCUSSION BEYOND THAT AND I
JUST HAD TO ADDRESS ONE THING
THAT WAS SAID BY THE OPPOSITION
WHICH I'VE HEARD IN THIS
CONVERSATION BEFORE WHICH IS
CONSIDERATIONS ABOUT THE
ECONOMIC IMPACT OF THIS ON
WOMEN'S WHICH MAKES ME AS A
WOMAN. LIKE I AM BEING TAKEN
BACK TO THE NINETEEN FIFTIES
AND THAT I SHOULD BE WILLING TO
ACCEPT RAPE FROM MY SPOUSE
BECAUSE IT IS IN THE BEST
ECONOMIC INTERESTS OF ME AND
PERHAPS MY CHILDREN WHICH IS
FRANKLY APPALLING TO ME I JUST
THINK IT IS WE ARE DONE WITH
THE DAYS OF PATERNALISM WHERE
WE DECIDE WHAT IS BEST FOR
WOMEN. AND WHAT IS BEST FOR
VICTIMS OF RAPE IS FOR RAPE TO
BE TREATED LIKE RAPE I DON'T
CARE WHO THE PERSON WHO
VICTIMIZES YOU IS WHETHER THEY
BE YOUR SPOUSE OR A STRANGER OR
SOMEONE IN BETWEEN IT IS RAPE
AND SHOULD ALL BE TREATED THE
SAME AND THAT IS WHAT THE
AUTHOR IS DOING HERE TODAY AND
I THINK THIS IS COMMENDABLE
WORK I THINK OUR LAW IS
OUTDATED AND NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED AND I'M GLAD WE'RE
DOING IT AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENT.
YOU MAY CLOSE UP RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. SO I WANT TO THANK
YOU TO FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD- I BELIEVE THAT THIS
HAS. OBVIOUSLY NEED TO BE
UPDATED. I AGREE THAT RAPE IS
RAPE. AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE- DO THE RIGHT THING.
BUT WE'RE NOT. TRYING TO DO
WHAT WE THINK IS RIGHT. WHAT I
MEAN BY THAT IS MAKING SURE
THAT A BILL DOESN'T HARM. EVEN
THOUGH IS TRYING TO HELP. AND
THAT. AS AN AFRICAN AMERICAN
MALE. AS CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE. THAT SOMEONE HAS
COME FROM A CIVIL RIGHTS
BACKGROUND. AS A FATHER. WHO
HAS A DAUGHTER WHO'S MARRIED.
WHO DOESN'T WANT HIS SON IN LAW
RAPING. HIS DAUGHTER. BUT MOST
IMPORTANT. AS A SEXUAL ASSAULT
VICTIM AND SURVIVOR OF A PET A
FILE. AND A FAMILY MEMBER. THEY
TRY TO RAPE ME. I KNOW MORE
ABOUT SEXUAL ASSAULT. THE FAX
THE DEVASTATING EFFECTS THAT
COULD HAVE ON AN INDIVIDUAL.
AND I FIND IT. PROBLEMATIC.
THAT WHEN I ASK QUESTIONS. AND
I WILL READ TO YOU TO LET ME OF
THINGS THAT I WAS CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT WE MADE
RECOMMENDATIONS SO THAT NOT
ONLY DO WE CLOSE THE GAP SAID
NO ONE GETS AWAY WITH RAPE. I
REPEAT I AGREE THAT RAPE IS
RAPE I'M A **** ABOUT FIFTEEN
TWENTY TIME. AT THE THINGS THAT
WERE SAID TO ME AS WE WERE
GOING THROUGH THE ANALYSIS OF
THIS. I'M JUST GOING TO LAY IT
OUT. SO THAT YOU KNOW WHAT I
WAS LOOKING AT. AND THAT I WAS
NOT TRYING TO STALL THIS AS THE
CHAIRED THIS COMMITTEE BECAUSE
THE CHAIRED THIS COMMITTEE I
DON'T HAVE THE LUXURY. I'M JUST
LISTENING TO ONE SIDE. AT THE
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE. I HAVE
TO LISTEN TO ALL WOMEN. THAT
ARE IN MARITAL SITUATIONS. AS
SOMEONE THAT GREW UP AND THAT'S-
IN A FAMILY WHERE THERE WAS
ABUSE GOING ON. I KNOW HOW
DEVASTATING THAT IS BUT I ALSO
FIND IT APPALLING THAT I HAD DE
ACE. COME TO ME AND TELL ME
THAT I SHOULDN'T WORRY ABOUT
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
AFFECT BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE
BECAUSE WE DON'T GET MARRIED IT
IS MOSTLY GOING TO GO AFTER.
WHITE MEN. THAT TO ME THAT'S
RACES PERIOD SIMPLE LAST RACE.
THAT'S WHAT BOTHERED ME. NOBODY
EVER ASKED ME AS A SEXUAL
ASSAULT VICTIM NOBODY S. B. FOR
A BLACK MAN TO ADMIT THAT WAS
ALMOST STOPPED SODOMIZED BY
HIS. FAMILY MEMBER. IT'S
PROBABLY THE HARDEST THING THAT
ANYONE CAN DO. AND SO WHEN I
HAVE SOMEONE LOOK BEFORE YOU
BERMAN ON THE CROSS OF THE OF
THE LAWN OF MY OPINIONS. YOU
NEED TO GET TO KNOW ME. YOU
NEED TO GET TO KNOW MY PAIN. IF
YOU DON'T KNOW THAT. DON'T MAKE
ASSUMPTIONS. ABOUT WHY I WANT
TO GET MORE INFORMATION. ABOUT
A PARTICULAR BILL ESPECIALLY
WHEN I'M DEALING WITH. D. A.'S
THAT ARE TELLING ME THAT THEY
CAN WEAPONIZE THIS. AGAINST
WHITE MEN. VICTIMS RIGHTS
SHOULD NOT BE A WOULD IGNORE IT
ABSOLUTELY NEVER NEVER NEVER
BUT YOU SEXUAL ASSAULT VICTIMS
ANY VICTIM SHOULD NOT BE A WAR
IGNORED. I HAVE A STATEMENT.
THAT WAS WRITTEN FOR ME. BY MY
NEW CHIEF CONSULTANT FEMALE
LATINA BECAUSE EVIDENTLY YEP I
BRING IT UP IS VIEWED. AS A
MALE NOT BEING CONCERNED ABOUT
A WOMAN. AND THEIR THEIR THEIR
RIGHTS IN THEIR ABILITY. TO
HAVE CONSEQUENCES THAT THEY
WANT. I AGREE THAT RAPE IS RAPE.
THAT IS WHY IN TWENTY SIXTEEN I
SUPPORT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA IS BILL AB
SEVENTY WHICH DECLARES THAT ALL.
FORMS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT ARE
CONSIDERED RATE. BUT EVEN
THOUGH RAPE IS RAPE NOT ALL
VICTIMS ARE THE SAME SOME
VICTIMS MAY NOT WANT THE
PERPETRATOR SPOUSE TO GO TO
PRISON THIS IS FROM MY MAIL.
CHIEF OF STAFF DOES NOT MEET
TALK. SOME VICTIMS THIS IS THIS
CAN BE FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS
SOME RESIDENTS STATED FOR THE
SAKE OF THE CHILDREN BECAUSE
THEY WANT TO RECONCILE AND YES
SOME OF IT FOR FINANCIAL
REASONS BUT THE OTHER IS WHAT
IF A WOMAN DOESN'T WANT.
BECAUSE OF THESE REASONS THEY
DON'T REPORT RAPE. WHAT IF THEY
DON'T REPORT BECAUSE THEY DON'T
WANT THEIR HUSBAND TO GO TO
PRISON OR HAVE A SEXUAL
OFFENSE. ON THEIR RECORD. NOW
YOU VICTIMS CHANGE THAT PERSON.
TO STAY IN A MARRIAGE OR TO
STAY IN A SITUATION THAT COULD
BE DIFFICULT. SOME VICTIMS MAY
HAVE GIVEN UP A CAREER OR NOT
BUT YOU NEED TO GOTO SCHOOL
AND CAN'T AFFORD TO LOSE A
SECOND OR POSSIBLY THE ONLY
FAMILY INCOME WHICH IS WHAT
WILL HAPPEN IF THE COURT MUST
SENTENCE A PERPETRATOR SPOUSE
TO PRISON. FOR PEOPLE AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THAT
ACTUALLY MEANS SOMETHING. IN
ADDITION REQUIRING MANDATORY
SEX OFFENDER REGISTRY WE'LL
HAVE BEEN EVEN MORE LASTING
CONSEQUENCES SUCH AS DIFFICULTY
OBTAINING FUTURE EMPLOYMENT AND
STIGMA TO THE FAMILY. CURRENT
LAW ALLOWS THE COURT TO TAKE
THE VICTIM'S WISHES INTO
CONSIDERATION. AND
UNFORTUNATELY IN A MANY WAYS
THIS BILL WILL PREVENT THAT.
AND SO WHAT I WANTED TO DO WITH
THE HAVE MORE DISCUSSION WHAT I
WANTED TO DO IS WHEN I ASKED A
QUESTION ABOUT. HOW INEFFECTIVE
THIS LAW THAT WE HAVE NOW IS
AND HOW WE CAN CLOSE THE GAPS
LIKE YOU WOULDN'T BELIEVE SAID
NO ONE. THE FIRST ONE THAT'S
ONE TOO MANY. BAD NO WOMEN HAVE
TO SUFFER THAT. IN ADDITION IF
SOMETHING HAPPENS WHERE AND
I'VE BEEN A DIFFICULT DIVORCE.
WHAT PEOPLE DON'T ALWAYS TELL
THE TRUTH. AND THAT PERSON SAYS.
TO THE LAW ENFORCEMENT DID THAT
SOMEONE RAPED THEM. AND THAT
HAS HAPPENED BEFORE I DON'T
WANNA HEAR THAT OR LOOKED AT
LIKE WHY WOULD YOU SAY THAT
ABOUT WOMEN. BECAUSE THERE
ISN'T. AN INDIVIDUAL NAMED
EMMETT TILL THAT BECAUSE OF A
LACK. YES BY WHITE WOMEN. HE
WAS BRUTALLY KILLED. SOMEONE
LIFE TO LAW ENFORCEMENT. WE
SHOULD MAKE SURE THAT THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM DIDN'T
GO AFTER THAT IF YOU DON'T
BELIEVE ME YOU NEED TO GO TO
EQUAL JUSTICE INITIATIVE BRYAN
STEVENSON THE ALABAMA TO SEE
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE TO BE
LYNCHED. AFTER AMERICAN BEEN
LYNCHED. I'VE HAD WOMEN CAUCUS
MEMBERS AND MARRIED WOMEN TELL
ME ABOUT THEIR CONCERNS AND MY
SUPPOSED TO IGNORE THEM. DO YOU
WANT ME TO IGNORE WHAT THEY
SAID WHAT DO WE NEED TO BRING
THOSE COMMENTS IN HERE LISTEN
TO THEM. A FIGURE OUT A WAY WE
CAN HELP EVERYBODY. RAPE IS
RAPE. RAPE IS RAPE. THE REASON
I BROUGHT THIS HERE THE REASON
I'M GOING TO ASK YOU BETTER GET
MOVED OUT. IT'S BECAUSE I AM
HOPING. THAT WE JUST DON'T.
RUSH TO JUDGMENT JUST BECAUSE-
IS THE THING TO DO OR WHERE
FRAYED. TO TRY TO ACTIVELY MAKE
THIS DONE CORRECTLY AND I HOPE.
AT THE- THAT THE SUPPORTERS.
AND OF THIS ANY AUTHOR. WILL
WORK WITH ME AND THE
PROSECUTORS ALLIANCE THE REASON
I'M MOVING FORWARD WITH THIS
COULD THE PROSECUTORS ALLIANCE
SAID THAT THEY WOULD WORK WITH
ME. IT THERE IS A PROBLEM. IF
IT ADVERSE CONSEQUENCES NOT
ONLY ON BLACK AND BROWN FOLKS.
BLACK AND BROWN FAMILIES IF HIS
DETERIORATION OF THAT. THAT WE
WOULD COME BACK. AT THE
BEGINNING OF NEXT YEAR IF WE
HAD TO. I MAKE THOSE CHANGES
BECAUSE- WE CAN WE CAN START A
LAW IN IN JANUARY FEBRUARY AND
DO AN URGENCY CLAUSE AND MAKE
THOSE CORRECTIONS THAT'S WHAT I
OFFERED. THAT WE WOULD DO THAT
WE WOULD TAKE THIS TIME TO DO
THIS. AND SO I KNOW THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT'S NOT ONLY VERY
IMPORTANT. TWO TWO WOMEN TO
MARRIED WOMEN AND YES TWO MEN.
MEN WHO ARE AND NOT WHO WERE IN
GAY MARRIAGES THAT COULD HAPPEN
TO WE NEED TO TALK ABOUT THOSE
VICTIMS THAT ARE PART OF THAT
ALSO. AND SO IT IS EXTREMELY
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. THAT WE
TAKE THIS VERY VERY VERY
SERIOUSLY. AND WE MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYONE- HAS THE RIGHT.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T.
TURN THIS LAW INTO SOMETHING
THEY BECOME SOMETHING DAMAGING
THAT WE HAVE TO FIX LATER. AND
WITH THAT CALL FOR THE. ON AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE BY SOME
MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA THE
MOTION IS DO YOU PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER HI CONSIDER IRAQI LACKEY
ADDED BARRICADE HAND BACKHAND
HI COURT. WORK AT A SAN DIEGO
SAN DIEGO I SEE ARE TO THE- TO
ATHLETICS WICKS I BELIEVE. WE I.
THAT MEASURE PRESS PASSES
REGULATIONS. NOW DURING. THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE. THE. I
HAVE BEEN WITNESS.